hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from round three of the LT box
Norway championship Magnus Carlsen with
the white pieces takes on Alexander
Greece shocked and I'm not gonna mention
if it's the classical or the Armageddon
not to spoil anything for you I would
like to decide that for herself during
the game you will you know check out the
moose and see which of it it could it be
and that's what about no video yesterday
I really had a fever and could barely
speak so I mean sometimes I will do a
video even if I'm not feeling all that
great but yesterday I just wasn't one of
those days and since we haven't shown
any photos from the this event yet
here's a very nice photo by Leonard
tortoise he's the official photographer
of the event and there we have it
all of them Wesley so Maxie Marshall
agraja Alexander II shook Sharma media
of ding clear and you young he 11 Arno
Magnus Carlsen Vishwanathan Anand and
Fabiano caruana all of them here 11 you
can see always you know most most
colorful person in the tournament always
with his big smile
Carlson always there with his very nice
hair on and you know in the front as
usual Fabi rocking his jeans and
sneakers I like it
you can see that a Greek is you know
much taller than everyone else if you
don't know that maybe also you'd
appreciate that information you can see
my videographer giving Carlson the
deadly stare if some of you don't know
mama drf was the last person to defeat
Carson in class one time for Matt last
year in the bill chess festival but so
far in 2019 constant has not lost a
single game well we we still don't know
how this game will turn out so you know
but until until now and you know the the
rest of the the happy crew so there you
have it I do hope you enjoyed that very
nice photo by Leonard Otis I will put a
link to his artwork in the description
below so feel free to check it out
really some amazing photos there so
without further adieu and it's very
interesting we haven't had a nice
Grunfeld game in a while so I hope you
enjoyed this as well Knight to f6 we
have C 4 and G 6 sorry about that nice
the C 3 and B 5 so the graphics setup is
on the board C capture Sun d5 Knight
captures and e4 we go for the main line
of the green field knife captures B
chapters and Bishop to g7 and now Bishop
to e3
we have c5 attacking
quite strong center and now rook the c1
there are a lot of possible moves here
you could develop the the bishop tonight
but look to c1 you you want to get this
rook away from this nasty diagonal as
soon as possible anyway so Queen to a5
by griffix
putting pressure on this diagonal now
the thread is C captures on d4 with
Queen to d2 now by Crossin and castles
by Grisham Knight to f3 and here we have
Bishop to g4 Magnifico it's interesting
in the tournament we covered not so long
ago the the Abidjan tournament the code
noir rapid event Knights the d7 was
played here in a game between ding Liron
and Wei Yi and the way he won a very
nice game there against a well in in the
Greenville but Grisha goes for a
different lineup to g4 and out d5 just
grabbing more space in the center this
is the most often played move in this
position and it's interesting there are
a couple of moves here for example
Bishop captures an f3 just arraigning
White's pawn structure on the Kings side
is the most often play move here and
even though most games in the database
ended in a draw in this line black won
more games than white so it is I don't
know maybe in such a top competition
against Carson you might want to go for
a move like that but Grisham could goes
for
b5 and it's a it's a really nice line it
was only played once in 1987 year I was
born
against Rob wit and the yo.hannes 1 mill
and it ended in in black winning a very
nice game in the Netherlands
championship but in that game black went
for the white went for the bishop
captures on c5 it is the strongest move
recommended by the engine but Causton
ignores the c5 cone he just continues
development Bishop to e2 and Bishop to
e2 is a new move so here I don't know
how far gray should prepare this b5 idea
maybe some of you have caught the
interview after the game so if you have
do share so I'll give it a heart so
everyone else can enjoy but I have not
so I don't know but as of this moment
like I said we have a completely new
game nights to the 7 Grigio continuous
development with ideas of capturing an
f3 maybe I'm getting this nice the e4
maybe even pushing c4 getting and
getting it the c5 all depending on what
white place across the simply castles
with bushel captures to know of course
that the bishop can capture you don't
have to ruin your porn structure so it's
very safe to Castle kingside
and now see for take you know closing
everything here on the queenside
making sure the seat respond remains a
constant target the bishop attack said
the Queen attacks it this night cannot
come to b6 the a4 and also the knight
can attack it so this is what Grisha
wants out of the position but should
back to e to buy Carson now you have to
make room for this f4 pawn as obviously
you're not going to be playing on the
Queen side rook F to d8 Mike Lee shook
and now comes f4 we have Knights the B 6
with ideas of getting this Knight way
for an attack from the c3 pawn like
we've mentioned and now after the point
has been pushed to a for now butcher
back to f3 with further control of the
center and now Queen to a3 a very
important move by glitch okay as you'll
see a later on I'm just gonna have a
nice sip of my water and constant now
prepares an attack on the King side we
have h4 and green shop of course
counters in the center with east six and
cross and ignores him with well and
here's one of the reasons why Quinto a3
was such a nice move if you could play
d6 here and well-supported would e5 that
would be really awesome for white but
here the the rook and the Queen are
guarding the d6 square so great shock
had this in mind before playing a6 after
a six with h5 by carson completely
ignoring this counterattack in the
center and here if you capture white
will just push 'if I've nothing to worry
about there nicely controlling the d4
square you're gonna push f5 here you can
even capture a lot of ideas for white so
here after h5 with Knight to the a for
now Ganesha goes after the pawn and now
just H captures on g 6h capture send g6
and cos and continues the attack with f5
and now there are a couple of
possibilities here for example you can
grab the c3 pawn but you can't grab it
with the night if you grab it with the
knight then you get captures in g6 and
after you capture Bishop to g4 going
after the pawn here and even after you
defend it it's just gonna be e 5 you're
gonna block the bishops a control of the
night here so it should be a much better
position
for white on the other hand you can grab
it with the bishop but are you really
gonna give up your your dragon in a
position where your king is being under
attack white would give up the rook here
very you know gladly Queen captures
Queen would come to f2 now there are a
lot of ideas here like mushroom before
attacks the Queen controls h8 followed
by Queen h4 to h8 mate you know just too
many darks where weaknesses to even
consider such a thing
so after f5 Grisha decides on he
captures on a5 with he captures on f5
and now Queen back to d6 you know the
Queen has to come help out with the
defense now brush up to a 4 kicking the
Queen away from the d6 square Magnus
wants to push this point well to d6 and
further on Queen to b6 check King to h1
and now comes G captures on f5 there
were some other ideas here but I don't
know some of you mentioned that you
don't enjoy disgusting engine line I
call them disgusting that because they
are disgusting but it's because you know
we're human so we're not supposed to
play like that
but I will mention Queen f6 here as a
nice resource for black it's very
counterintuitive I mean as you're
allowing Bishop to g5 but even Bishop to
g5 is not best for her for white white
would just go F captors and g6 and after
Queen captures pull d6 and it would be
just very hard to play this you're not
getting rid of this pawn your knight is
so far out of the game you have the
bishop prepare very strong after black
tries to get rook into the game you can
go d7 even and after Luke to b6 it would
just be well a very very tough position
to play for black but it was blacks best
resource because well you probably see
Queen f6 button see Bishop g5 and you're
like now we're not going into this but
okay I just mentioned it G captures an F
I was played by grey shock and now cross
and just continues d6 and it would be
much better if the Queen was over on the
King side instead of on b6 because here
the King is somewhat loose on the King
side all of course and species are going
for the king and well-greased chokes
pieces are not really camping where they
should be camping rook a to be eight
English who prepares to bring the rook
into the game but now Bishop to d5
and our group tries to bring the light
into the game I'd like to see five
Bishop to g3 now opening up an attack
towards the f5 pawn we have nice the
East six and are just rook captures an
f5 and now there are a lot of dangerous
in the position for example if we should
continue something like a five or or
let's even before then rook captures on
f7 will be deadly after King captures
just rook everyone check you can't go
here you have to you know allow white to
capture than I initially captures here
and black just falls apart so after Luke
afters and I five-degree shook now
decides to give up the exchange with
rook capture somebody six but now
costing just grabs the exchange with
Bishop captures Queen captures and now
comes Queen to e3 so threatening a lot
of ideas here we have Queen to b6 trying
to trade Queens but cross and is not
interested he's he's better on the board
so he prefers to keep the Queens on the
board f7 is very weak the bishop the
rook the Queen are all eyeing the f7
point you cannot move the knight we have
looked FA defending and I just rook to
f1 bring in more pieces to attack the f7
pawn here aggression defense we have
Knight to d8 but now comes Luke to h5
and now it's a very hard to defend Queen
here to here will be checkmate grisha
played Queen to c7 and now feel free to
pause the video here and try to find the
best idea for white to play in this
position I'll give you a couple of
seconds it's not it's not all that
trivial so you know think twice before
you before you agree on the move I
really enjoyed this position because
it's it's a kind of position that will
often happen in your own games but for
those of you who found Queen to f5
congratulations this does win but it's
not the best because Queen a5 es you to
threaten checkmate but if the rook moves
then the King does have an escape route
here here and and so on so it is
possible but NDA was still in the game
but it's not the best move here across
and played Queen to e4 instead it's much
better
again threatens checkmate you cannot
push f5 as the pawn is pinned and of
course the rock yet just is met with
Queen captures on e8 so there is no
contraband it was in this position
almost 34 that Alexander really should
resign the game so once again
congratulations for those of you
found Quinta efore I mean it's it's it's
a quintet 5 is nice you will win the
game but it's always better to win the
game you know sooner than later
so that's the game I do hope you enjoyed
it I would like to thank often the money
Genaro salerno peter Friedel press miss
la mesa alcove ski and Robert Fischer
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank y'all for watching and
I will see you soon I hope I will be
feeling better and then we can show some
more games from this very nice
tournament and then check out the
standings as it is already round three
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day